America is burning for six night in a
row
anger flooded streets across the deeply
divided country this scale of civil
unrest has not been seen here in decades
in George Floyd's home state protesters
marched against systemic racism and
police brutality it's the new lynching
you know and then and it's new coded
language and the way that our president
represents himself and and has a
following of KKK members you know all
this stuff across the country a wave of
anger has been unleashed I think we're
at a tipping point to be honest with you
I think that I think this is what
happens when you have hundreds of years
of oppression and hundreds of years of
peaceful protests that seemingly
accomplish nothing I have been
discriminating against my entire life so
like I'm used to the Trayvon Martin's
I'm used to the amount our babies so I'm
just tired of it I'm tired of the
narratives I'm tired of the hashtag
there were also scenes of unity as
officers showed their solidarity with
protesters shaking hands
but in Washington
tensions spiked outside the White House
as the president blamed left extremists
and infiltrators for the unrest radical
left criminals thugs and others all
throughout our country and throughout
the world will not be allowed to set
communities ablaze we won't let it
happen
it harms those who have the least but
some experts say there is also evidence
of far-right extremists stoking the
violence the president's response has
drawn criticism from both sides of the
political aisle with some calling for a
measured response to the crisis all
right let's talk about the ongoing
protests and political implications in
the US
Natacha lindstedt is a political
scientist and professor of international
relations and comparative politics at
the University of Essex in England
Natasha good to have you with us
you were in Los Angeles during the
police attack on Rodney King and the
unrest that followed in 1992 how do you
compare what you saw then to the
protests now well the 1992 riots were of
course incredibly tense and in fact over
60 people died and thousands were
arrested and many were injured but the
difference was it only lasted six days
it didn't spread over to a hundred and
forty cities and there was actually a
lot of inter-ethnic tension between
Asian Americans and African Americans at
the time in the LA riots this is
completely different this has spread to
be something that really affects all
Americans and we're seeing more
solidarity among people of color and
also white Americans who feel that there
have been tremendous injustice against
African Americans who touched a lot of
people right now looking to the White
House for leadership President Trump has
not addressed the people he has not
sought to calm tensions to this point
how much are these protests testing his
ability to lead the nation well yet
again we see another situation that
Trump is unable to respond to because he
takes it all very personally thinks it's
all about him instead he has
declared antifa some left-wing group a
terrorist organization that doesn't help
he's Fanning the flames of racism and
refuses to acknowledge his role in
fueling right-wing groups and in
legitimizing this this type of behavior
of racism against African Americans we
have seen protests similar protests over
the past few years that have targeted
some of the deep systemic inequalities
that you see in u.s. society the deep
racism after Eric garner was killed in
2014 for example yet nothing much seems
to have changed in that time is there
any indication that we these actual
these protests right now could address
these efforts it's really hard to say
but I've never seen protests that have
been so extensive as I mentioned over
140 cities are involved in it seems to
be involving all different groups of
people that have just had enough I mean
one of the things important to
understand about racism in the US and
about how African Americans have been
unfairly targeted is that on average
about two African Americans that are
unarmed are killed by the police every
week and they're two-and-a-half times
more likely to be killed it's just that
most of the time these things aren't
videotaped so it may be just the end of
the road here for people they feel that
they've done enough they've tried enough
they've tried all kinds of peaceful
protests and hopefully we're going to
see more people uniting as some of the
video footage showed behind the need to
keep the police accountable and to to
understand that black lives matter
all right Natasha Allen said political
scientists at the University of Essex
thank you so much